[Musique]
moi j'ai un vrai petit faible pour
isabelle le voilà donc j'ai ri j'ai
commencé à être un peu tôt à l'âge de 30
ans des dragons et je sais pas pourquoi
et c'est ça quelle mystérieuse dans une
vie j'étais gardien de répondre à ton
moi même le sait pas je ne vais
peut-être les dragons c'est plus fort
que moi c'est une forme de talisman
aussi ça me protège les bleus partent en
plus forte et donc l'agent les deux
roues et je travaille sur un troisième
apparaissent dans patron mais je les
montre jamais j'en parle mais c'est mon
jardin secret j'ai fait un voyage
particulier en moto que j'ai baptisé la
route du sable
c'est très bizarre j'étais avec mes
petits neveux dans le nord de la
bretagne et où leur construise un bac à
sable à côté de la maison ils ne se
rendent compte que le sable du coin
n'était pas bon et elle est comment dire
trop épais j'ai pris la route aux suis
parti du nord la bretagne du tram c'est
la bretagne
j'ai chargé la haute aucune grosse
routière avec ses valises de sable elle
s'est affaissé logo voisine et et je
suis reparti dans le sens pour remplir
le bac à sable sont à faire un petit
show pas moi qui 300-400 km aller retour
et j'ai appelé ça
l'épopée du sein voilà c'est new wave
[Musique]
impossible de choisir parce que je me
suis découvert cette envie ces dernières
années de rester journaliste parce que
c'est mon premier métier c'est ce que je
voulais faire enfants et puis j'ai
découvert le plaisir d'animation et
comme j'aime la radio aussi d'avions
mais c'était plaisir totalement
différent quand on informe c'est un
métier commence à peindre est quand on
arrive c'est encore autre chose il
laisse le plaisir sont différents et je
serais incapable de choisir ce que je
vais essayé de m'appliquer à faire ces
prochaines années c'est bien de cultiver
ce ça fait un peu à part d'ailleurs
d'être à la fois journaliste est à la
fois à une matin